i heard die all the time skiing yeah  yeah it's uh i mean  yeah but it's also i the few times that  i've gone it is very fun it's super so  fun you know and and uh you know if  you're a radical person yeah who wants  to stay  i imagine now that like jill is taking  care of both your boys and has to like  open a can of peas for you it feels very  unradical for this radical yeah you know  what i mean like you really because  you're sort of like  yeah  no i know i'm saying  she's gonna wash my kale trying to yeah  yeah yeah she's got to rinse your kale  yeah you can't do it it actually hurts  okay let's try not to make one laugh oh  wow okay  that's interesting about power  throughout  i do enjoy i do  enjoy a good laugh